hello I'm Patrick Stewart and I am doing
the wired autocomplete interview you
know you've seen it before so you know
what it is
who is Patrick Stewart I am who is
Patrick Stewart married to my wife is
called sunny ozell oze double-l and she
is a wonderful wife and a fabulous
sinner who is perfect Stuart's best
friend
the commonly known friendship that I
have is with Sir Ian McKellen whom I've
worked with many times and who I'll be
frank with you I am in love with but
then so is my wife in love with him too
so that's all right
who Patrick Stewart's Yorkshire poem I
think I know what they may be referring
to I grew up in the north of England in
the West Riding of Yorkshire which meant
that I spoke with the Yorkshire accent
but it wasn't just an accent it was
actually dialect which means that you're
not just mispronouncing words you're
using different words altogether so I'll
give you a little example I will
certainly ask my slave then the mother
and father were you off because that had
to be owed not Susanna well then it'll
be bad we had cough West Riding dialect
who is Patrick Stewart Jimmy Neutron
Jimmy Neutron I think Jimmy Neutron was
a character in a film that I played but
I don't know give me another is Patrick
Stewart British yes I am British
I'm actually an Englishman born in the
county of Yorkshire is Patrick Stewart
vegan no I'm not I think I have an
excellent diet with many of the right
kind of healthy things but no I'm not
vegan is Patrick Stewart left-handed no
I wonder why you would ask that is
platter Xterra a nice guy
I don't know shall we put it to the vote
one two three four five six seven eight
of us in this room how many say yes it's
almost whoo
analyst seven of the eight said yes I'll
talk to you later is Patrick Stewart
related to Martha snippet oh that's
lovely no I am not related to Martha
Stewart but I have Messer several times
in I adore is Patrick Stewart related to
Kristen Stewart no I'm not but Kristen
and I of course worked together we were
both in the remake of Charlie's Angels
and I liked her very much and I've
admired her work for a long time how
Patrick Stewart stays in shape well
that's a very timely question because I
have over my lifetime had trainers and
worked in gymnasiums when I was a
teenager I played a lot of sport I did
get into really serious trouble with my
athletics coach at the school I went to
because I was taking part in a rather
important sports event and I was a
sprinter but that evening I had a
performance on stage and I realized if I
went through to the final I was going to
miss my stage performance that night so
I threw the race and I got into so much
trouble
how did Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen
meet
20th Century Fox invited us both to
being a little hardly known series at
all called x-men we had adjoining
trailers when you're in those kind of
movies you spend more time sitting in
your trailer than you do in front of the
camera so Ian and I hung out together
drinking tea and later in the afternoon
maybe something a little stronger and we
got to know one another and the charm of
it was that we found we had so much in
common and by the way he married us my
wife and me he performed the ceremony
wonderful how did Patrick Stewart become
a knight I don't know the answer to that
question but that evening I did call my
wife and I said oh hello is that lady
Stewart on the line because of course my
wife has got it
we'll also now be married to a night she
went with me and my brother and
sister-in-law to the palace ten years
ago and I was dubbed on both shoulders
with a sword yes that is actually how it
happens the Queen has a sword in her
hand and she does this and says arise
Sir Patrick
how old was Patrick Stewart starfriend
47 when hose off at the Plaza I think
there was about sixty when I stopped
being shown the card that of course I'm
back being the same character again now
so the show goes on how did Patrick
Stewart and Seth MacFarlane meet Seth is
a huge Star Trek fan and I had enjoyed
his work for a long time and then he
asked me to play a role in his animated
series American Dad and I play the
deputy head of the CIA and his name is
Bullock and he's a wonderful time and
appalling creature but a wonderful
character to play was Patrick shirt in
Harry Potter that's such an unkind
question no I was not in Harry Potter I
was even asked to be in Harry Potter so
that I could arrogantly turn it down
that every other actor that I know in
that I'm coaster was in Harry Potter
except certainly in the calendar that's
what made his famous that we weren't in
Harry Potter was Patrick Stewart
knighted with a with a Klingon sword Her
Majesty the Queen doesn't possess a
Klingon sword well actually she might I
suppose no there was no Klingon weapon
involved in any of that was Patrick
Stewart in Excalibur well done it was a
wonderful experience it was the first
epic film that I've ever been in I
played Leon des grands who was the
father of Guinevere next one what was
Patrick Stewart's
first movie funny enough I was lying in
bed this
morning thinking about this movie it was
called Hennessy but it was a movie
starring Rod Steiger and I had a day and
a half's work on that film very strong
role and it is I got shot I got killed
which is why I was a day and a half
working on that film what is Europe done
for us well in the last 40 years the
European Union has brought economic
success to our nation
it has brought open borders where our
European families can move backwards and
forwards and it has created a peaceful
Europe but now utterly misguided and
self-interested politicians have taken
us out of Europe because they think we
should be on our own it's going to be
calamitous I missed one out what Awards
did Patrick Stewart win I've got I think
three Olivier Awards there was a theater
awards in England I think - Evening
Standard awards which are also for
theater work I've had a Tony nomination
the more important question is that what
have I not won Academy Award I've been
nominated for Emmys I've never gotten
any I've been nominated for Golden
Globes and never got a Golden Globe but
I would really like a Tony an Academy
Award anybody who's listening who
happens to have an influence in that
direction
I'd be grateful what is Patrick Stewart
known for being a delightful
good-looking charming witty and generous
companion what is Patrick Stewart up to
well I had a very exciting morning
my wife's Valentine present was
delivered to us my wife loves ancient
olive trees and so that is what I've
given my wife as a Valentine's present
it's now planted in my garden and it's
amazing it is 38 years old we've given
it a name it's called Valentina
does Patrick Stewart knit oh yes I did
yes my mother was a knitter and she
taught me how to knit does Patrick
Stewart have a dog presently no but
about four years ago my wife and I began
fostering something I passionately
suggest if you haven't got a dog you
look into but foster only from shelters
and the shelter that I foster from which
is called wags and walks here in Los
Angeles it specializes in getting dogs
from high kill shelters does Patrick
Stewart drink Earl Grey tea very
occasionally I drink a tea called
Yorkshire gold every morning that's how
my day starts does Patrick Stewart
own a vineyard well yes of course
jean-luc Picard he inherited a vineyard
from his family and now he lives there
in our new series does Patrick Stewart
sing country songs well I do have a
modest little album out oh recorded
maybe three four years ago Patrick
Stewart sings cowboy classics well if
you've made it this far first of all
congratulations on having such patience
or good taste depending on how you look
at it but I have had a good time which
makes one of us doesn't it and I want to
thank everybody for inviting me to do
this the only other person I'd seen do
this was Paul McCartney so I feel that
I'm in very good company